let's continue our coverage of cpac next
i want to look
at a donald trump jr speech and then
we're going to look at some interviews
with attendees
and i have some bigger picture thoughts
about cpac which i'll tell you
in a moment earlier in the weekend
donald trump jr
spoke and uh everything from even just
how he was introduced
to what he said to the strange applause
lines to an interview
he gave it's all really horrifying stuff
but in the straw poll that was conducted
and announced at the end of cpac
other than donald trump uh don jr was
actually i believe
third in terms of 2024 presidential
candidates this is not a guy who should
be ignored this is a guy who
has a lot of the same terrible instincts
of donald trump but is far more
competent and a far better speaker
so let's get right into it here is don
jr being introduced introduced by his
girlfriend
uh former fox news host kimberly
guilfoyle it's all like just cult of
personality type stuff please join me
in welcoming a true warrior and the
embodiment of
america first movement donald trump
jr
[Applause]
weird skip
[Music]
yeah so you get the idea but just
complete cult of personality
uh there's a very kind of totalitarian
authoritarian you know uh uh
cult stuff that continues to happen at
these events
and um i mean just to give you a sense
of it
here in this next clip you'll sort of
hear a crowd member yell
trump one during junior's speech and he
lets them cheer for a full
minute i mean it's a it's a level of
sort of like um
deistic idolatry that should
scare all of us because of how divorced
from reality it is
[Music]
they're just cheering for trump one and
that's a defiant and an inspirational
thing to say at this event
yeah so you get the idea of what
cheering for lies sounds like
then there's a really strange moment
where i
he seemed to lose his ability to speak
coherently for a moment
said something weird about texas and
then kind of looked around
i still don't understand this moment but
take a listen to it
you know texas has always led the charge
well till about like a couple months ago
and then austin sort of took over like i
don't know guys like texas was leading
the chart
you're still top 25
but we got to work on that stuff because
those people have lost their minds huh
right
so very strange you know you may want to
save the anti-texas material for when
cpac is in a state other than texas don
i don't know i'm not
an expert on this type of thing but a
very very strange moment
and um then things just continue to get
weird i don't
let's just even take a look at this next
one i'm not even sure what we're going
to see here
can't allow it to happen we need to push
back
oh okay so there's the trump one thing
and then let's skip ahead when he goes
back to speaking i guess
he's the most popular president ever
he's significantly more popular than
barack obama was in 08 especially
in the inner cities because he has a
track record of not being racist
his son definitely didn't drop
let's say words that i don't even want
to use abbreviations for with letters in
them
so then he really goes into the hunter
biden stuff
and i've been saying for a while this is
a party that it
they're off of issues they're not doing
any political issue stuff anymore it's
stop communism which you'll see in the
interviews with the with the attendees
it's stopped joe biden joe biden has
dementia
uh they're undoing everything trump did
and they're redoing things obama did
and then he really goes in on hunter
biden and calls them
a piece of garbage i say that they say
oh you're making fun of people with
addiction i go
let's just talk about this for a second
i totally understand addiction it's
terrible
we all know people that have suffered
from it it doesn't absolve you from
being a total piece of garbage in every
other aspect of your life
this used to be an event at which
they did talk about policy policy i
didn't agree with
policy i found to be completely immoral
and disgusting
but the president's son is a piece of
trash
is now what they're doing here's one
last clip here's don jr being
interviewed before or after his speech
and it's very clear he's going to be as
involved as trump
in 22. so i'm going to be very involved
the reality is you know i'm the father
of five young kids i'm a patriotic
american i love this country and i look
at what's going on
and someone has to push back you know
there's not many people that have sort
of the privilege of having a big
platform there's not many people who
have a big platform that are actually
willing to use it
to sort of go against the mainstream
narrative i think the facts are on my
sides and it's a battle we have to have
so i'm happy to do it it's an honor
i'm telling you guys this is a guy who
if he gets the
oxygen trump got in you know 10 years
as as of right now we have a country
that would elect don junior president
and he's far more competent than donald
trump i think the left should actually
be scared
uh because the the right has proven they
they will elect anybody
and if trump can get elected i think don
jr can get elected as well it's scary
stuff
let's now talk about the trump
supporters one of our sponsors is steady
md
primary care the easier and more
affordable way to do primary care and
they're giving you
50 off because you are in my audience
you just answer a few questions steadymd
will match you with a licensed
primary care physician that's tailored
to your needs
you'll have a one-hour virtual
appointment and start
a meaningful relationship with your new
doctor
and from then on your doctor will be
available to you by text phone and video
chat
it's not some random doctor on call
your steady md doctor has a limited
number of patients
you get the attention you deserve and
they can help you with anything your
primary care doc
normally would it's very cool how it
works
you don't need insurance it's just 99
bucks a month
no other fees or co-pays for visits take
the free quiz and see which doctor is a
perfect fit for you
you'll get 50 off your first month when
you go to steadymd.com
pacman no risk no long-term commitment
the link is right underneath the video